[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
ne pas affaiblir le gouvernement de
kaboul c'est la demande faite par le
ministre talibans des affaires
étrangères aux états unis une
déclaration alors que des pourparlers
entre les deux pays ont débuté
aujourd'hui à douala
nous sommes pas encore commenté ces
propos
[Musique]
l'attention loin de retomber entre le
mali et la france avec cette déclaration
choc du premier ministre valiant dans un
entretien à un média bus ils accusent la
france de former des terroristes sur
voit son territoire choguel
la maia qui avait déjà suscité l'ire des
vannes ul mâcon après avoir accusé la
france d' à bordeaux en plein vol suite
à l'annoncé d'une suspension des
opération barque anomalie nous y
reviendrons dans ce journal
enfin nous ferons le point sur ce
nouveau samedi de mobilisation contre le
pass sanitaire en france plusieurs
manifestants dieu à paris réunissant des
centaines de personnes une nouvelle
mobilisation alors que dans quelques
jours les tests pcr et antigénique ne
seront plus remboursés par la sécurité
sociale pour les personnes non vaccinées
ce sera dès vendredi prochain
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
des pourparlers entre kaboul et
washington se sont donc ouverts
aujourd'hui à doha au qatar pour deux
jours les demandes des talibans aux
états unis ne se sont pas fait
d'attendre le ministre des affaires
étrangères on a formulé une très clair
ne pas déstabiliser le gouvernement en
afghanistan une mise en garde david kahn
amir khan bouteille à laquelle
washington n'a pas encore réagi écoutez
nous leur avons dit clairement que
tenter de déstabiliser le gouvernement
en afghanistan n'est bon pour personne
de bonnes relations avec l'afghanistan
profite à tous rien ne devrait être fait
pour affaiblir l'actuel gouvernement en
afghanistan ce qui pourrait engendrer
des problèmes pour le peuple
et parmi les points qui vont être
évoquée entre américains et talibans à
doha la sécurité et la lutte
antiterroriste c'est ce que nous
explique david rigoulet roze rédacteur
en chef de la revue orient stratégique
en l'occurrence et les talibans qui se
sont engagés vis-à-vis des américains
justement dans le cadre de l'accord de
doha de février 2020 à éradiquer ils
l'ont fait d'ailleurs aussi à l'endroit
des russes à éradiquer le la présence de
l'état islam de la branche effectivement
du khorassan de l'état islamique en
afghanistan
mais mais il ya une succession de
d'attentats ces derniers ces derniers
jours qui pose le problème qui touche
les talibans là où le bât blesse parce
que en réalité de la légitimité des
talibans affiché c'est d'abord en termes
de sécurité et là manifestement ils
éprouvent des difficultés pour faire
prévaloir cette sécurité dans au niveau
de l'ensemble du pays et justement c'est
pour parler à rite au lendemain d'un
nouvel attentat en afghanistan un
attentat suicide
dans une mosquée de koundouz dans le
nord-est du pays au moins 60 morts des
dizaines de blessés sont à déplorer
l'attaqué a été revendiquée par le
groupe terroriste état islamique au
khorassan c'est dans ce contexte que le
haut commissaire des nations unies pour
les réfugiés a appelé à débloquer les
fonds promis pour l'afghanistan à ce
jour seuls 30 % de l'enveloppé demandée
par l'onu a été à débourser
de cash and is mon stock de places à la
plupart des promesses n'ont pas encore
été réellement décaissés matériellement
financièrement je pense donc que c'est
ce que nous exhortons les états à faire
maintenant honorer ses promesses ces
promesses ont été faites il s'agit donc
de les honorer
car nous avons besoin de ces ressources
rapidement windows
phone
avant qu'une solution ne soit trouvée je
prévois une crise humanitaire plus
importante est de mon point de vue
spécifique
je prévois des déplacements massifs
parce que les gens lorsqu'ils n'ont pas
de soins de santé qu'il n'y a pas d'eau
courante ou qui n'ont pas d'argent ils
vont se déplacer ils se déplaceront
peut-être en dehors de l'afghanistan et
je pense que nous devons absolument
essayer d'éviter cela
absolute les préventes
vous le disais en titre l'heure ne
semble pas à l'apaisement entre le mali
et la france lors d'un entretien accordé
hier soir à l' agence de presse russe
ria novosti le premier ministre de la
transition à bamako a accusé la france
d'avoir contribué à la déstabilisation
du pays et à la propagation du
terrorisme des déclarations alors que la
tension était déjà à son comble entre
les deux pays les détails avec hélène
masculin
c'est une véritable bombe lancée par le
mas liés à la france le premier ministre
par intérim passe à l'offensive
dans un entretien à l'agencé russe ria
novosti ce vendredi ils accusent l'armée
française d'avoir attirer et former des
groupes terroristes à kidal une enclave
de l'est du mali et qu'il
est là qu une enclave qu'est ce qu'elle
a fait à sardines organisations
terroristes internationales déclaré pas
les avec
une branche d'al-qaïda au mali sans chef
les français en lice et des agents pour
voir une autre organisation c'est la
phrase qu'il a créé cette enclave ils
ont découpé armés qui sont entraînés par
le déficit français nous allons les plus
un tacle dirigée contre emmanuel macron
qui pendant ce temps présidé ce vendredi
le sommet afrique france organisé pour
la première fois depuis 1973 sans les
chefs d'état du continent face à cette
invective du gouvernement de transition
le quai d'orsay sollicité par rt france
n'a pas encore réagi les relations entre
les deux pays sont au plus bas début
juin paris annoncé vouloir mettre fin à
l'opération barkan lancé il ya sept ans
un retrait militaire d'ici 2022 vu d'un
mauvais oeil par les autorités maliennes
qui dénonce un abandon de la france la
nouvelle situation née de la fin de
barkan plaza le mali devant le fait
accompli et les choses à une espèce
d'abandon en plein vol nous conduit à
explorer les voies et moyens pour mieux
assurer la sécurité d'une manière
autonome avec d'autres partenaires des
propos très mal accueillie par le
président français j'ai été choqué ces
propos sont inacceptables
alors que hier nous avons présidé à
l'hommage national aux sergents maxime
blasco tués au combat au mali c'est
inadmissible
c'est une honte et sa déshonorent ceux
qui n'est même pas un gouvernement une
remise en cause de la légitimité du
gouvernement de transition qui a attisé
la colère de mac os
le président français a également
déclaré que sans l'implication de la
france le pays aurait longtemps été
envahie par les terroristes ce vendredi
paris a annoncé avoir tué un cadre
jihadistes dans la région du sahel
à partir de vendredi prochain le 15
octobre les autotests ne suffiront plus
à valider votre pass sanitaire une
annonce via un communiqué ce matin du
ministère de la santé une mesure pour je
cite encourager la vaccination les tests
pcr est donc également antigénique ne
seront plus automatiquement remboursées
par l'assurance maladie pour les
personnes en tout cas qui ne sont pas
vaccinés pour l'être il faudra donc être
vaccinés et muni d'une prescription
médicale ou être mineur les futurs
tarifs 44 euros pour les tests pcr 22
euros pour les tests antigénique
effectués en laboratoire pour rappel
près de 6 millions d'adultes n'ont pas
encore reçu deux vaccins anti qu'ovide
des annonces alors qu'un nouveau samedi
de mobilisation contre le passé ni terre
a lieu aujourd'hui à paris mais aussi
dans toute la france parmi les
rassemblements qui était prévu celui des
gilet jaune il a démarré à 14h30 du côté
de la bibliothèque françois mitterrand
un défilé qui a suivi pour nous lucas
léger et plus tôt
la manifestation des gilet jaune contre
le pass sanitaire s'est terminée sur la
place de clichy après un itinéraire d'à
peu près 9 km depuis la bibliothèque
françois-mitterrand des manifestants
scandant le slogan liberté et résistance
contre le pass sanitaires et les sûr
qu'ils estiment désormais obsolète
puisque la situation sanitaire
s'améliore ils craignent aussi désormais
pour les enfants alors que le
laboratoire pfizer a déposé une demande
de mise sur le marché pour ces vaccins à
partir de 5 à 11 ans ils craignent aussi
purement et simplement la mise en place
d'une vaccination obligatoire pour tous
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
manifestantes avec qui j'ai pu parler au
cours de ce cortège bon prof qui a toute
manière de faire que de l'imposer
impasse qui fait une sorte d'apartheid
en fait il ya des gens les les gens qui
on parle pas salutaire ils ne peuvent
pas ils ne peuvent pas aller à tel ou
tel endroit est ce qu il ou ils peuvent
ça fait vraiment une séparation des
personnes c'est pas que je sois contre
les vaccins et les vaccins ont rendu par
le passé de nombreux services mais j'ai
pas confiance dans ceux là dans celui ci
et j'ai pas confiance non plus dans ce
qui nous incite à le prendre mal fait à
le faire faire voilà c'est une question
de confiance en réalité est aujourd'hui
on est en train de nous dire qu'on va
nous faire payer les tests pcr alors
qu'ils sont là juste pour protéger la
population et aussi si on nous les a
imposées jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est pour
protéger la population je ne suis pas
contre le vaccin je suis contre
l'obligation vaccinale qui est
totalement
différente pour moi donc chacun a le
droit en fait d'ouvrir normalement avoir
le droit de pays de liberté de choisir
pour son corps c'est que j'estime juste
pour moi et qu'on arrête de nous dire
que le pass sanitaires c'est quelque
chose de sanitaires ça n'a rien à voir
fin septembre il était 9,2 millions de
personnes éligibles à la vaccination qui
n'avait toujours pas entrepris les
démarches pour s'immuniser contre le coc
vite 19 il avait 14 4 % de personnes
souffrant de maladies chroniques comme
le diabète qui n'avait pas complété par
ailleurs leur schéma vaccinal
du côté des personnes soumises à la
vaccination obligatoire il ya eu de 1400
suspension en ile de france et environ
3000 sur tout le territoire d'après le
ministre olivier ferrand mais ce chiffre
pourrait être plus important enfin le
syndicat sud a appelé à la grève la
semaine prochaine dans le secteur de la
culture un secteur qui est toujours
soumis aux passes sanitaire
autres rassemblements contre le pass
annie terre celui des patriotes près du
pont de l'alma tout à leur écoute et
justement au micro de sébastien dufour
leur chef de file folle envie niveau ce
dernier qui réagit donc et cette
décision du ministère de la santé de ne
plus reconnaître les autotests antilles
qu'aux vide à partir de vendredi
prochain
ce qu'il démontre là se démasque ces
politiques ça n'est pas sanitaires même
chose quand ils disent les doses les
autotests ne seront plus valables après
le 15 octobre il démontre que c'est donc
politique et non plus à lutter c'est que
c'est pas assez cher même les doubles
vacciner en fait sont pas à l'abri parce
que dès janvier prochain et vous
expliqueront qui va il faut faire une
recharge parce que votre double vaccin
il sera plus valable vous savez limité
baisses très vite donc frattin une
troisième injection israël dans la
quatrième donc en fait personne n'est à
l'abri donc wait ceux qui cautionnent ça
ou restent silencieux parce qu'ils sont
eux-mêmes vaccinés ou double vacciner ce
qui n'est pas le cas de tous il ya des
doubles vaccins qui sont contre ça déjà
mais ils doivent pas cautionner ça parce
que tu as on savait retombées aussi sur
le coin du museau à un moment ou un
autre c'est quoi le but on fait ce
qu'elle est là cette folie alors qu'on
voit bien que dans les pays qui sont
moins vacciner ou qu'ils ont pas fait de
confinement par ailleurs et ça on a en
fait la même épidémie c'est globalement
la même chose partout ce qui serait
quand même gouvernement ça doit
interroger un discours de florian
philippot qu'elle n'adhère pas daniel
leca vice-président eu délit de la
région des hautes france mais aussi
aurélien véron conseillé à l'air à la
mairie de paris
le vaccin n'est pas un référendum quand
je me suis fait vacciner je n'ai pas
signé que je soutenais macron je suis
très critique de la politique macro mais
le vaccin est recommandé par des
scientifiques et les politiques n'ont
fait qu'obéir aux recommandations des
scientifiques les publications pas
seulement en france dans le monde entier
scientifiques officiels publics
défendent le principe vaccinale est le
principe de ces hors la loi sanitaire a
été préconisée par pas mal de deux
scientifiques dans le monde mais c'est
pas français donc dire je n'ai pas
confiance semaine macron je vois pas le
rapport avec le fait de se vacciner ou
pas aujourd'hui le vrai sujet il est de
savoir comment on va préparer et je le
dis un débat démocratique qui arrive ce
sera l'occasion pour tous les
mécontentements exprimés ou au contraire
ceux qui sont satisfaits aussi pouvoir
s'exprimer le débat démocratique qui
s'ouvre c'est celui qui alors on peut
s'en féliciter ou pas mais en tout cas
c'est le débat présidentiel qui rythme
la vie démocratique de notre pays et
c'est là où devront s'exprimer les
encore une fois les satisfactions où les
mécontentements et c'est là où l'on
verra quels sont les sujets importants
pour le pays et on reste en france pour
le 40e anniversaire de l'abolition de la
peine de mort une cérémonie s'est
déroulée à la mi journée au panthéon à
paris
parmi les invités d'honneur robert
badinter l'ex ministre de la justice qui
avait donc défendu la promulgation de
cette loi devant le parlement en 1981
âgé de 93 ans l'ancien président du
conseil constitutionnel appel à une
abolition universelle alors qu'une
cinquantaine de pays appliquent encore
cette sentence de mort même souhait
évoqué par le président emmanuel macron
également présents à cette cérémonie
quarante années
se sont écoulées depuis le vote de
l'abolition en france
la marche vers l'abolition universelle
là depuis lors cessé de progresser
la france se doit
d'être
tous présentent au premier rang quand il
s'agit de combattre la peine de mort je
vous annonce donc en ce 9 octobre 2021
que la france va relancer le combat pour
l'abolition universelle
dans le cadre de la présidence française
de l'union européenne
nous organiserons à paris avec
l'organisation non gouvernementale
ensemble contre la peine de mort une
rencontre au plus haut niveau
rassemblant les sociétés civiles des
états appliquant
encore la peine de mort ou un moratoire
afin de convaincre leurs dirigeants de
l'importance et de l'urgence de l'abolir
le chef de l'état qui défend une avancée
civilisationnel majeur avec robert
badinter il exhorte à l'abolition donc
universelle de la peine de mort retour
en images sur les étapes de ce long
processus
[Musique]
demain grâce à vous la justice française
ne sera plus une justice qui tue demain
vous voterez l'abolition de la peine de
mort il n'a jamais jamais été établi une
corrélation quelconque entre la présence
ou l'absence de la peine de mort dans
une législation pénale et la courbe de
la criminalité sanglante
[Musique]
le
il est certain que le mouvement vers
l'abolition universelle se poursuivra il
est certain est la réponse des fils papa
mais il est certain que l'abolition
totale
très gros freins
[Musique]
en chine place aujourd'hui au 110e
anniversaire de la révolution de 1911
l'un des rares événements célébrer à la
fois à pékin et taipei de quoi rappeler
pour pékin le concept de chine unique
alors que les tensions en vous crescendo
avec taiwan théo coup
le décorum se veut solennel car
l'événement est d'importance devant
plusieurs centaines d'invités le
président chinois shipping commémore le
110e anniversaire de la révolution de
1911 qui renversa la dernière dynastie
impériale celle des kings une cérémonie
dont le leader communiste s'est servi
pour rappeler sa volonté d'unir taiwan à
la chine continentale
yves repiquet 20 juillet réaliser la
réunification de la patrie par des
moyens pacifiques dans l'intérêt général
de la nation chinoise y compris des
compatriotes de taiwan
[Musique]
ce qu'ils oublient leurs ancêtres
trahissent la mère patrie et divise le
pays ne finissent jamais bien ils seront
rejetés par le peuple est jugée par
l'histoire
séparés par un détroit la chine
continentale et l'île de taïwan sont
divisés depuis 1949 et la victoire des
communistes
la révolution de 1911 reste pourtant
célébré des deux côtés du détroit des
festivités qui prendront une tonalité
particulière cette année ces derniers
mois pékin multiplie les incursions dans
l'espace aérien taïwanais les dernières
datant de la semaine passée avec près de
56 avions chinois repéré pour la seule
journée du 4 octobre pour la présidente
de taïwan l'île ne souhaite pas de
confrontation mais se défendra s'il le
faut awan cnas et
taiwan ne cherche pas la confrontation
militaire elle espère une coexistence
pacifique stable prévisible et
mutuellement bénéfiques avec ses voisins
mais taïwan fera également tout ce qu'il
faut pour défendre sa liberté et son
mode de vie démocratique
soutenu par les états unis la démocratie
taïwanaise ne cache plus ses velléités
indépendantistes une ligne rouge pour
chine bing qui a fait du concept de
chine unique un des piliers de la
diplomatie chinoise une situation qui
semble inextricable
alors que les visites de responsables
occidentaux se multiplient sur l'île
provoquant la colère de pékin
politique en autriche fragilisée depuis
plusieurs semaines par une enquête pour
corruption sebastian kurz vient
finalement d'annoncer sa démission selon
le parquet le chancelier autrichien est
soupçonné d'avoir utilisé des fonds
gouvernementaux pour financer des
sondages d'opinion partiellement
manipuler sebastian kurz à a déclaré
qu'il se retire pour je cite la
stabilité du pays tout en réfutant de
fausses accusations
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images
les habitants de beni en république
démocratique du congo inquiet après à la
détection ce samedi d'un nouveau cas du
virus ebola un enfant de 3 ans est
décédé à l'hôpital et ce simple mois
seulement après l annonce de la fin de
cette dernière épidémique fait six morts
dans la région
à tripoli en libye une manifestation de
migrants a eu lieu aujourd'hui devant le
haut commissariat des nations unies pour
les réfugiés
objectif dénoncer leurs conditions de
détention leurs conditions de vie
vendredi plus de deux mille d'entre eux
s'étaient enfuis d'un centre de
détention provoquant une forte
répression des autorités
et puis retournement de situation en
république tchèque a annoncé vainqueur
dans un premier temps le parti du chef
du gouvernement arrivera finalement
deuxième des élections législatives 99 7
% des votes ont été dépouillés c'est le
parti together une coalition composée de
trois partis libéraux conservateurs qui
est donc finalement arrivés en tête
et pour terminer cette édition retour
sur le parlement européen qui dit non à
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
faciale par la police résolution non
contraignante adoptée cette semaine est
pourtant un peu partout dans le monde
cette technologie s'est banalisé les
détails avec l'édito de nadège ad razak
la vie privée et l'anonymat bientôt des
concept archaïque c'est en tout cas ce
que fait craindre clé review une
entreprise américaine créée en 2017 qui
a collecté et identifiés plus de 10
milliards de photos pour alimenter un
gigantesque système de reconnaissance
faciale
comment ont-ils fait pour se constituer
une telle banque d'image et bien les
siphonnant sur google facebook ou encore
twitter
ces géants du net ont d'ailleurs mise en
demeure la start up américaine pour
qu'elle mette un terme à toute collecte
d'image sur leurs sites respectifs et
qu'elle supprime toutes celles qui ont
déjà été stocké le règlement de youtube
interdit explicitement de collecter des
données qu'ils puissent être utilisés
pour identifier une personne pour le
dirigeant de claire viau son entreprise
a agi en toute légalité
notre système est conçu pour ne prendre
que des informations disponibles
publiquement
d'accord mais quand on ouvre un compte
facebook ou instagram on ne signe pas
pour finir dans une banque données
internationales vendus en tchéquie et
encore moins pour être suivie dans tous
ses déplacements par des logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale d'ailleurs en
fait si on sait par qui on compte pas
moins de 2200 organismes publics et
privés à travers le monde et des
opérateurs télécoms des établissements
scolaires des banques ainsi que le fbi
et une centaine d'autres organisations
de maintien de l'ordre la technologie
aurait notamment largement servi aux
forces de l'ordre pour identifier les
personnes qui ont pénétré de force dans
le congrès américain le 6 janvier
dernier en belgique quand la police
serait effectuée entre sans une et 500
perquisition avec ce logiciel et avait
jusqu'ici toujours nié son utilisation
et pour cause la pratique et dans ce
pays tout bonnement illégal la
reconnaissance faciale est certes une
piste intéressante à utiliser sur le
long terme pour soutenir le
fonctionnement de la police mais cela
n'est bien entendu possible etc avec une
base légale correct afin que les
éléments obtenus puissent être utilisés
légalement administrativement et
judiciaires bain et en france c'est bien
c'est évidemment tout aussi illégale
comme dans toute l'union européenne
ne serait-ce qu'en vertu du rgp dès le
règlement général sur la protection des
données il interdit formellement depuis
mai 2010huit toute utilisation des
données personnelles non consenti
pourtant une enquête de bast une news
qui dit avoir eu accès aux registres de
claix review recense quelques 400
connexion au système de personnel du
ministère de l'intérieur l'information
vigoureusement démenti place beauvau
le ministère de l'intérieur n'a aucune
information sur clear view l'ogre de la
reconnaissance faciale à la légalité
douteuse pourtant plus de 400 recherches
ont été effectuées par la police dans la
base de données outre sa légalité
douteuse la technologie clear view
semble avoir ses limites aux etats unis
c'est un noir américain a été arrêté à
tort en 2019 à cause de la
reconnaissance faciale robert williams
c'est son nom il a passé 30 heures en
attention parce qu'un logiciel avait
jugé identique la photo de son permis de
conduire et l'image floue d'un voleur de
montre comment expliquer à mes filles
qu'un ordinateur s'est trompé mais que
la police l'a quand même écouter il
semble donc urgent de mettre en place un
cadre légal clair uniforme et globale
pour anticiper certains scénarios de ce
type c'est ce que tente d'ailleurs de
faire le parlement européen l'instance
s'est prononcé mercredi en faveur d'un
rapport qui prône l'interdiction totale
de la surveillance biométriques de masse
3 177 voix contre
248 un premier pas car le texte adopté
n'a pas de force législative mais il
vise inspiré la commission européenne
nous envoyons un message clair les
droits fondamentaux sont irrévocables
pour la toute première fois nous
appelons un moratoire sur le déploiement
des systèmes de reconnaissance faciale à
des fins répressives
ces technologies ayant démontré leur
inefficacité et souvent abouti à des
résultats discriminant en attendant la
reconnaissance spatiale semble avoir de
beaux jours devant elle preuve en est
claire violation de développer son outil
à travers deux aspects le premier celui
de rendre plus net une image floue en
ayant recours à l'apprentissage
automatique pour tenter d'imaginer ce à
quoi elle pourrait ressembler la seconde
innovation repose aussi sur
l'imagination et tente de représenter le
visage d'une personne masquée elle
s'appuierait cette innovation sur un
modèle statistiques établies à partir de
données récoltées un scénario qu'on n'a
pas pu voir venir pas même dans les
pires films de science fiction c'est la
fin de cette édition merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le résultat d'un droit peut réserver
bien des surprises pour mieux comprendre
où vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]